you both have heard me say this uh what
you guys did with this film I'm Blown
Away by it's one of my favorite films of
the year the level of artistry on
display is insane and that's all I have
I just want to say thank you for making
it you guys have a I'm joking
um there are
I was hoping for a reaction it was just
a smile
I'd be happy to leave
throwing it in man right there are so
many incredible sequences in this film
that I I'm just curious is there one
particular sequence that you truly are
looking forward to audiences seeing just
because of well you know the way the the
the animators did something or whatever
the reason
well there's a couple of them uh I know
what yours is which I share but there's
another one it's it's the whole sequence
um in the bedroom where uh Geppetto puts
Pinocchio to bed and before that he puts
Carlo to bed it's just so beautifully
animated and so it's so tender and uh I
think it reads so true and it was all
done all that stuff was done by one
animator and he spent two years in that
bedroom and I think the beauty of that
not for him perhaps but for the audience
is that he was really able to just sink
completely into that scene yeah you know
it's only a few minutes long at most but
he spent two years on it and just nailed
it I think I think that the other thing
that is beautiful is they are visually
uh staged very similar so you know that
Geppetto is saying good night to two
different Sons and when he's turning off
the light he cannot call Pinocchio son
yet so it's a beautiful moment of
character uh to me the the best for me
right now today is gonna be the the talk
and the church between yeah where they
discuss Christ and Pinocchio in in the
same single discussion not only from a
writing point of view an animation point
of view but from a visual point of view
I think that set of the church and the
way Frank laid it the way it was
animated the Precision of the screenplay
is just a perfect perfect scene
Guillermo I know we've discussed many
times Your Love of keeping things from
the movies you make and I'm I'm just
curious with this particular project how
did you let anything go
you know I I would Age I have come to
accept that I'm getting only 20 puppets
I I have found a great maturity
but also the sense
yeah well the sense it's hard to let go
of those but but I have only limited
real estate
what was for the great responsibility
with uh with owning those yeah puppets
because you have to you have to take
care of them I I will say this if you're
allow it anybody that lives in the New
York area can actually come and for a
few hours be be in front of the feds at
MoMA on the exhibit of the art of
Pinocchio you see the real sets the real
puppets with real light uh lit by Frank
or cinematographer and you get a really
close experience to what it is to
animate a film it's a beautiful very
large exhibit that is going to be here
for a few months Mark I believe that you
were the head animator on Fantastic Mr
Fox yeah I was the animation director on
that one yeah and so I'm just curious
how has has the art form changed at all
in the years since making that film or a
stop-motion pretty much the exact same
it's been throughout you know time it's
evolved a little bit the the technology
keeps moving forward to make the process
a little bit easier and a little bit
faster but it doesn't get easier or
faster because what you do is you take
that technology and you think oh I can
do this so why can't I do more so I
think that's probably true of uh you
know most undertakings once you have the
tools you want to push them right up to
the Limit
although you know with Pinocchio we
weren't really trying to push the edge
of this technology we were trying to I
think get more sort of it was more about
the emotion and the story than the
technique Yeah we actually went back
into mechanical puppets largely rather
than printed faces which was the the
tendency yeah
the mechanical faces really give the
animators more control over the
performance and lastly we can get
subtler things sometimes was there
anything that you guys actually strongly
disagreed on during the making of the
film or was it always pretty much eye to
eye on everything
and we were in difficult moments like uh
we like the sequence the the shooting
Squad yeah well it's hard to let go of
that one no I don't think so I mean we
there yeah and there was a chess playing
sequence that we shot all of essentially
which was beautiful beautiful really
really nice animation and very funny uh
and ultimately we cut it because it just
interrupted that hurt flow that that
hurt and and there's one one shot at the
end when we're swimming about water that
market convinced me we should cut and I
still wake up in the middle of the night
going ah we should have that shot but I
I actually I'm joking everything we I
mean we have an incredibly organic
collaboration and gentle I mean neither
of us uh have a moment of like a Rubicon
we we understood why things needed to go
yeah
I have to ask you as a fan of of the way
you two work together on this
um and is there talk between the two of
you of doing another stop-motion movie
together or is it sort of like this
takes so much out of you you need to
take a break Mark is already preparing
his own uh project yeah right yeah yeah
and I'm already writing I'm preparing my
next live action Friday so
the answer is no but I like him
here an individual question for you uh I
thought Cabinet of Curiosities was so
well done and I I think it did well on
Netflix but I don't know is there any
talk of doing more episodes
you know we we got the the thing I
published on Twitter about my
like a billion views or whatever that is
uh it is a very mysterious process to
get the yes or the no uh either way is
good news for me because producing Aid
features in one year was really really
difficult uh so you know I would love to
provide another season to to get some
really interesting people behind the
camera protected and cherished uh but on
the other hand uh I have a feature
coming that I will start shooting
probably in August announcement soon to
come and uh and uh I know it would be
very difficult so in a way if if they
say yes we'll make the effort and do it
but if they say no I'll go almost
I understand gentlemen congratulations
uh thank you so much for making this
movie have a great day